you're just a guy walking down the
street that people cross the street so
that they're not near you
and friendships are so much harder to
build because this [__] is lonely try to
think about how you can do do little
little conversations to help their
emotional maturity so that they can
reach out to people and have deeper guy
French so you have to [__] it up yo your
whole invitation rescinded oh
all right today's topic looks like uh
someone who's trans became uh born a
female became a man and uh they're
having some regrets nobody told me how
lonely
being a man is I had closer friendships
with random women I met in the bathroom
before I transitioned at clubs because
of how open women are yeah when you go
to wash them you shut the [__] up
everybody do the Stalls you don't talk
you get in there you shut up you go
about your business exactly I ain't
trying to talk to the new beside me when
he got his dick out I'm not talking
wrong with you just because we're not in
a stall don't mean that when I'm using
the [__] urinal you're supposed to
make eye contact or say some [__] to me
hey what's up man hey don't talk to me I
got my dick out and you got your dick
out and it's in your hand don't talk to
me yeah cause a minute both people got
their dick out is gay
yeah when you peeing and you should be
like hey what's up how you doing huh
I straight I don't even want to see you
be like yo is it bigger no don't do that
don't I straight
this man out here crying because he he
can't talk to other dudes at the urinal
I think you chose the wrong gender my
friend you're not ready for this life
you can't talk for the yeah we don't we
don't talk as a matter of fact yeah
there should be a space between y'all
there should be a wall if there's if you
don't build it if there's if there's
urinals forget the Mexicans if there's
urinals keep the men out you go pay you
see someone paying that you don't go
next to him I'm Canadian I'll vote for
Trump for that you go next I want that
wall you leave us Pace we out here
having dick hands and you want to talk
to me I want to hear uh the blow dry
and men's pooping in the back I don't
want to hear what
no nobody's talking no shut up Dad
eight years of transitioning
because women are just so much more
vulnerable and deep and Men We deep it's
just a different kind of deep it's just
not deep in the same way and I wouldn't
call necessarily woman deep or man deep
they just it's just different I wouldn't
call the conversation that the girls
have in the washroom deep sorry
not gonna do that oh my God oh my God oh
my God oh my God that's not deep and I
think a lot of trans men feel this is we
knew what that depth felt like before we
transitioned we knew what it felt like
to like how people want to hug us
and have people want to talk to us
and have a community and then you
transition and you're just a guy walking
down the street that people cross the
street so that they're not near you
every time I see these videos I just
have to laugh because it's just like
it's like women who become men and then
afterwards
oh my God this is loneliness this shit's
hard it's like yeah man it's a privilege
man's privilege oh because the man's
like yo this [__] sucks
this [__] sucks sometimes I think there
is a difference between men's
relationships with other men and women's
relationships with other women and I
think most people have had relationships
most sex understand there's differences
my experience having Foster
relationships with men
it just takes longer and takes more
investment before a lot of that
vulnerability sets in and you've been a
man now according to your own words for
eight years very likely that you may
have not fostered these traditional male
relationships where you get to get that
sense of deep vulnerability and it
doesn't always manifest itself in the
same way but it doesn't mean it's not
always powerful or meaningful or things
like that I'm going to show you in my
life in the men I know there's been once
a very intense vulnerability and it's
been you know things that are welcomed
and they're fine if you want to be a man
and then also I know for me I prefer my
male relationships and friendships to my
female relationships friendships but not
everyone's gonna drive with the same
thing so I can actually understand why
he is suffering and why he has this
issue if he's looking for that kind of
relationship as of now man or presenting
as a man it's hard for him to have that
it's not the same it's just like one at
home it's just like whenever I talk to
some of my girlfriends and the lesbian
ones you know and they're like yeah I
can Mac I can Mark a girl the same way
no you can't you're a girl it's a whole
for Universe you do not Mac other it's
not because we're after the same thing
that the result or the experience is the
same yeah if I go to a girl man she got
her guard up if you go it's a different
thing and friendships are so much harder
to build
and people are colder and what's hard is
none of this invalidates how real and
raw women and people who are in marginal
ice groups feel about CIS white men
although that's valid
but I also Now understand why this side
rate is so much higher in men
because this [__] is lonely
and I'm an emotionally mature man
bring it in brother one of us one of us
it seems like you've really transitioned
welcome to the club brother now you know
how tough it is man we had before it
wasn't a test it wasn't the blockers
because once you hit that oh [__]
they look at me and see a threat oh now
you are mad when you walk by a park and
the mom hides her kids
oh now you're a man yeah welcome to that
man life another reminds me more of the
fact that I'm a man than when I don't
have my period thank you Jesus and when
I walk down the street and it's late and
there's a woman in front of me and I can
see she's scared I ain't trying to do
nothing but I already know yeah I'm a
man yay welcome welcome to the club just
want to welcome you oh what do you mean
I can't go to the park alone where
there's kids and the woman playing with
their kids no that's weird that's weird
yo I can't just I didn't believe in
trans stuff before but now I do he
really transitions yeah
[Music]
now you're even thinking about
self-delution welcome to the club like
I'm not saying I'm not saying it's a
good thing but it's it yeah it'd be like
that you're not getting in the club for
free be like that yeah
come on now don't come in when you
download apps you making the first movie
yeah
yeah everybody yeah
hell no welcome to one of us no my girl
caught me slipping yeah it's a game that
we play let's say she says I want to
watch a movie and I'm like you're gonna
sleep during that movie she's like no
I'm not I'm like okay and we watch the
movie and she sleeps in the movie what I
do is I film her and I shore later and
I'm like ha hey
got you slipping but this time she
caught me we're coming back from a trip
and I told her yeah I'm gonna eat and
drink in the plane and she says no
you're not you're gonna sleep you're
tired
went inside the plane
and despite the fact that it was a
couple arguing that in the back of us
and a baby couple of rolls down crying I
couldn't hear them
you know why
I was wearing those
the raycons earbuds
and sometimes in the plane is super
uncomfortable because it's too hot
and what you think happened water
resistant so everything was comfortable
they got you know sizable gel that you
can put and then it fits right in your
ear the quality of sound of those
Immaculate they have a bass sound that
is
different molds on top of that click on
the link below and get 15 off your
earbuds go to the link in the
description below or go to buy recon.com
Abba to get 15 off on us I know how to
build friendships and it is still really
really hard try to think about how you
can in your small little Community where
you feel safe
can reach out to women in your life and
just
help them feel it may be seen for a
moment
or
do do little little conversations to
help their emotional maturity so that
they can reach out to people and have
deeper guy friends so you have to [__]
it up yo your whole [__] invitation
rescinded oh
oh
we don't need women to talk to us to
help their emotional maturity listen
having female friendships then not all
of a sudden just raise my emotions
everything yeah it's so condescending
whenever I hear [__] people with
women who want to do this all the time
you need some female friends so they can
elevate your y'all shut the [__] up when
you hear men ever say women need to have
male friends to elevate anything my God
that [__] is so condescending and this
is [__] I don't like because all they
ever do this this issue all they ever do
when they talk about men's relationship
with other men is speak negatively about
it they do never speak about it
positively and the reason why I annoys
the [__] out of me is I know how
positive those relationships are and how
Irreplaceable they are now I don't [__]
on women having Christians with women I
think it's great okay I think it's great
I think it offers things and you should
have it if you can okay but I don't know
why men's relation with other men is
always seen as lacking or trash or
whatever it is it just takes more effort
to Foster and it's just a different kind
of reward I'm not even going to say that
it takes more time to Foster I'm gonna
say that it's really just different
because you know I got both I got male
friends I got female friends it's not
inherently just more difficult to Foster
marriage it's just really different all
right I'm not gonna no it is
and I'm not right and I have female
friends and it does not alleviate it's
just a different [__]
can you understand women's perspective a
little bit better sure but it does not
necessarily alleviate what you what
you're living I'll say that and I'll
tell you why it's easier to faster women
invest more time in their friendships
than men do and women are just more open
in general so it's a lot easier for them
to not only make friends but deep in
those Bots because they have more
flexibility and they prioritize their
friendships more he's talking about yo
make more friends what women have more
women friends I have both nothing that a
woman are making more friends with them
so yeah women are able to make friends
with themselves and everything and stuff
I'm talking about as a man perspective
having friends man friends and having
woman friends having women friends that
does not necessarily alleviate anything
what I see and that's what I live I'm a
live experience right so I'm gonna talk
about what I live right at some point at
some point it can be easier with men
because it's not going to be as much as
a fuss if we don't talk because they
kind of need that thing they need that
that that energy a little bit more or
that reinsurance that she's still here
and still friends
it's actually easier for me because I
don't have to if we don't talk we don't
talk it's not a thing I'm not pissed off
so it's gonna be easier with a guy than
with a girl
yes but for a friendship to deepen you
have to invest in each other that's just
is what it is so whether we're not we
need to talk every time or whatever
that's not the point is if you want a
relationship to deepen you have to spend
time you have to actually have
conversation sure and women are just far
more likely to do that than men are that
is that is statistically true so because
women are making more of an effort
obviously their relationships are going
to feel deeper or faster deeper in terms
of fostering that friendship there right
they're gonna be able to to talk a lot
but they're going to be able to talk
more but they talk more about they often
talk more about their feelings right
when you talk about your feelings it's a
different thing and if you have to say
something about them it can become very
much more complicated than if it's a guy
if I have a problem with my God friend
I'll go like yo listen this is this that
happened they really appreciate that
we're gonna talk it out and everything
is only fire oftentimes with a woman if
I'm like opened and I'm like yo this and
that happened is that what I said
turns into
how she felt
about what I said and no longer about
what I said
so in that sense it's going to be very
hard it's going to become very hard
where I on the male Contra part it's
often this and that in the third happen
that's how I feel or that's how you feel
I don't feel and there's going to be a
discussion about what happened where I
on the Mormon side you're going to have
a discussion and it's going to be about
how she feels about what you said
oftentimes okay so that can be that can
make that can be very difficult when you
try to deepen a conversation or how you
feel about certain things even not only
necessarily if there's something that
happens with that person or just talking
about different stuff in general you
want to talk about a subject and it
turns into how that person feels around
that subject and when you talk to a man
oftentimes we talk about the thing like
we have to decipher a lot of things
before we get to the core of the subject
that we're talking about and that's why
I feel sometimes it's easier with men
and it's faster with men but that's just
my how I see things yeah sure I think um
yeah I think maybe you find the pathway
to being in a friendship with men maybe
easier I think for most dudes that
pathway doesn't even really start
because most dudes report not having any
friends or maybe one or two friends at
most whereas women have a much healthier
social life and have better ties to
their families as well because women
invest more times than their friends and
their family which I think is a
wonderful thing they're prioritizing
things that matter men struggle with
that okay our men struggle now when they
do Foster those relationships I do think
that they're more powerful in my
personal experience but I think women
are far more apt at engaging in social
lives than men are
men or percent of their days gaming
they'll spend their days doing a lot of
other things but as far as like making
time to see their friends or see their
family sure a lot of time that be a
second day where women use seats at
their top of their products so that's
just something I noticed and it's not
just
from that even from work like mental
forego Vacations or forego spending time
with the family much more likely than
women in terms of Christmas or things
like that if it means they can make more
money they prioritize things differently
sure maybe that's because of
relationship expectations or what a kind
of pressure Society puts on men to be
overachievers but it's clear women are
just better at fostering relationships
than men are if you're being honest
most dudes have a hard time making
friends
most of you have a hard time making
friends I suspect that for those guys
being in relationship with them is
probably also really tough for women
because all of their social interactions
just come from the woman I imagine I got
to be kind of weird there's never been
me personally but I could see that being
a bad thing you know what I'm saying
like you got no friends and then you
start dating a girl and she's a friend
and then her friends become your friends
friends or a couple friends at the thing
but becomes him his friends as well
because he ain't got no friends so
whenever there's outings or a couple
outings they go together so they start
to connect but it's quit on her side
that does not rarely happen so when he
starts hanging out with her friends solo
I mean no not really but the only
connection that he has with the outside
and other people is at work or the the
friends of the girlfriend okay
then that's the weird like it's a
one-way thing you know I mean when
people call you that word and stuff like
that anyway but yeah I guess for the
trans man becoming uh um
a man for him uh basically meant that he
realized that men were lonely and he
wishes that essentially women could help
men learn how to Foster friendships
better
okay well I think it begs the question
which I think is a really important one
he's like why do you think men struggle
to make friends
because
this is not crazy right maybe when he
says women need to teach men maybe
there's some truth to it let's let's
take a second let's take a step back
before we go hey [__] you
which I already did earlier and let's
say there's some what can women teach
men about friendship is that something
that we can really learn is it some
biological social probably okay probably
I think it's a yeah I think there's a
possibility of there you know I'm just
being a baby open me being a little bit
more available like I learned that
having girlfriends I learned that when
they bring up it from shut the [__] up
shut the [__] up
they don't want your solution
there's one event they want to vent the
first step yo doesn't that happen don't
try to be logical with that [__] don't
try to solve the problem that's not what
they're here for they need to vent and I
think that that's that's a way
it taught me to read a bit more into
what people wanted and stuff like that
so same thing that happens with like I
was able to transfer transfer that into
my God friends and
understand what they just need to be
listened to or just not sometimes not me
poking at them to see more information
stuff like that just letting the door
open and more time than ever they don't
say [__] like my friends my God friends
they don't open up right away but they
know I'm available and open we move on
to other things and then they're gonna
proceed into eventually later on when
they're ready on their own time talk
talk to me about whatever the hell going
on but the girl side when they come to
you oh yo this Edition this should
happen and this shut the [__] up
not listen but there's not much to say
at some point you know I don't think men
need to take away women's vulnerability
I don't think they need to take away
from them like how women engage in
conversation and venting all that other
[__] because I'm not trying to hear
that [__] I you know a girlfriend that's
already enough I'm trying to hear that
from everybody else but but I will say
this one thing men need to do and
there's something I tell dudes even in
dating get some [__] hobbies that
make you a little bit social one and two
men got a prioritized relationship well
I mean well you can take any kind of
hobby whatever it is that brings you
around people that allows you for having
social interaction it doesn't even have
to be with the opposite sex when I say
dating I say dance related stuff because
you're often with the opposite sex but
even hobbies that virtue around other
dudes you know like for most men their
friendships actually come from their
Hobbies when you drove in a bike group
when you join a gun club when you draw
those things or a golf course they see
their friends that's how they do it it's
through activities a lot of men have
have social activities that are
generally anti-social or they'll spend
all their gaming but nothing in person
I'm not saying online relationships
aren't nothing but I'm just saying
General they're not a substitute for a
lot of real life relationships so men
don't invest enough in Social Hobbies
women do because I said dancing that's
gay
true or if it's not gay it's you cooking
other people right taking their wives so
when you're not being homosexual you're
stealing other men's wife whatever don't
explain to me how that's both gay and
well it is what it is all this just
Schrodinger's dancer
and cooking other people I'm going to go
and cook a bunch of Tonight Tonight I'm
getting on my bike I'm gonna just wheel
over there cuck and then come back [__]
anyway
what are you cooking tonight your wife
going out there cooking what's for
dinner we cooking your wife
anyways like I said
invest in some Hobbies okay I've seen
two week guys who have zero Hobbies they
just have the work life they go to a bar
and they go home that's not a hobby if
your social life is struggling get some
[__] Hobbies bro social Hobbies too
get into martial arts get into yeah
people such a community and friendships
come from these things that's what
people are lacking it's not women coming
here to do it's like dudes gotta
prioritize these things you know they
got to make time for their friendships
because then all of a sudden a year goes
by you ain't seen your homies he's like
yeah we still homies that's great but
you gotta invest that time you got to
put that effort in if you guys don't
make that time to see each other those
relationships will start to fade and
while you guys are still going to be
happy to see each other you're gonna
miss out important moments in each
other's lives times you guys could have
been there times you could have shared
when you were struggling so that comes
with priorities that's not some yes
women do that and that's great that's
not something women can give to us
that's something that we have to take
for ourselves that comes from
reevaluating how we view things valuing
our families seeing our mothers our
sisters our brothers whatever it is so
what do I take away from this video what
is experiences I understand welcome but
I don't agree with the solution that we
have to be more like women per se I
think that men just need to rearrange
their priorities for sure sure I think
that's what I would take away from it
the most
change those Hobbies
anything else no but yes let us know
what you guys in the comments we want to
hear from you